my friend would still be alive if he'd
had the price of his life he could have
been cured with surgery but the cost was
obscene everything's got a price human
life human hearts even dreams there's
nothing that isn't for sale hello and
welcome to hunt onto 101 series that
breaks down everyone and everything in
the Hunter hunter world and today we are
going to be delving into the brilliantly
hot-headed future dr. Leo Leo Hardy
Knight
Leo Leo Perotti Knight is a young man
who often gets mistaken for an old man
despite the fact that he is still a
teenager when he is first introduced
into the series during the hunter exam
arc at first glance they are would
appear to be incredibly narcissistic and
almost entirely driven by the goal of
attaining vast amounts of wealth and
look that's not an entirely inaccurate
assessment of his character however
there is a compelling reason that
informs his philosophy on life which
began during the Oreos childhood when he
lost a close friend to a fatal illness
although the real kicker being that the
illness was easily curable however lay
Oreo could not afford the cost of the
surgery required and so after the
passing of his friend Leo do then
developed two resolutions the first of
which being that he would one day become
a doctor so that he could heal anybody
he wished and secondly that he would
acquire vast amounts of wealth to fund
his medical studies as well as pay for
the supplies required to enact his
knowledge and the pursuit of the latter
goal is what would promptly Oreo to take
the hunter exam as acquiring a hunter's
license would allow him to access an
incredible abundance of cash through a
wide variety of means but through the
exam lay Oreo would also gain something
unexpected when he acquired three close
friends in the form of gun could a pika
and kilowatt all of whom were absolutely
instrumental in the order of completing
the various stages of the exam because
it should be noted now that despite
being the oldest member of this
friendship group the Oreos physical
abilities were as significantly lacking
when compared to everyone else
now the Otto himself is entirely aware
of this fact however what he does
possess is an exceptional will and he is
not one to back down from a fight even
if the odds are overwhelmingly against
him and especially if someone he cares
about is in trouble and this idea is
epitomized when during the first phase
of the hunter exam they Oreo chose to
engage in combat with Hisoka a decision
that would not end favorably for him but
putting his bravery and conviction on
display regardless but this isn't to
sell him short because the Oreo does
indeed possess incredibly advanced
strength stamina and agility when
compared to the average human
and in fact chairman natural even judged
that leo leo held combat prowess that
surpassed that of Bottura
who was a martial arts master in his own
right so they are can't be that weak
moreover an example of lay Oreos
incredible strength was seen in the
series when he was able to open the
first door of the Tzadik families
testing gate all on his own
although notably the scene was omitted
from the 2011 anime so the arrow seems
to wield some pretty decent skills he
just appears a bit lacking when we
juxtapose him against the many other
major characters in the series who to be
fair are absolute monsters despite that
they are quite often takes on the role
of older brother when it comes to his
friends always willing to stand up and
fight for their sake although he's
famously hot-headed and impulsive nature
does often end up causing more problems
than it solves but a prime example of
Leora are stepping up to help his
friends would come in the final stage of
the hunter exam Michaela was pit against
his older brother Ella me and Leora
proceeded to provide a huge voice of
encouragement and once again stood up to
a figure wildly more powerful than
himself
when alumi threatened to kill gone later
on Leora obtained his hunter's license
by default McKellar broke the rules of
the final stage by murdering boat owner
however lay oreo on with gone and korra
pika then immediately followed Killa
to cooker mountain in order to free him
from the control of the zoldak family
and following the success the group
disbanded promising to reunite in
york-new city in six months time alir
alir plan to use that period to study
for his medical university entrance
exams due to these priorities they are
also elected not to commence learning
nen until he had passed the university
exam meaning that by the time Leo did
reunite with the group he was far far
behind them in terms of Nan mastery only
knowing the very basics of the single
principle 10 despite this they Oreo went
on to play a crucial role in the events
of york new city which resulted in the
deaths of two members of the phantom
troupe and the forced exile of their
leader
Pirlo lucifer afterwards era took a bit
of a backseat in the story for quite
quite some time during which he
furthered his study of den and
discovered that he was an emitter an
affinity for which means that an end
user is naturally capable of separating
their aura from their body an example of
which can be seen in Lee oreos
ultrasound ability whereby he releases
his aura impulses around a selected area
allowing him to detect organisms or even
abnormalities within the human body but
these new skills later reappeared in the
series to visit Gunn in hospital who had
been gravely wounded from his actions in
the Chimera ant arc and utterly
disgusted by the lack of support from
God's father Jing Li REO once again
played the older brother and barged into
the hunter Association headquarters and
used another of his emitted abilities
known as remote punch to sock Jing right
the face now to fully understand the
madness that happened next it needs to
be said that Jing was less than popular
amongst the Association and this action
was met with rousing cheers and even
laughter from the hunters present as a
result and even against his will the
area would go on to receive votes from
many of the hunters to become the
association's 13th chairman hello it
should be said that this is partially
due to the actions of Jing who
manipulated and unknowingly Oreo to
become a hinderance in the election
however we also simply cannot ignore the
main selling factor here which is they
Oreos abundance of natural charisma the
proceeded to conquer the hearts and
minds of an absurd amount of hunters
during and after the election and to his
great credit if he'd kept it up Laird or
more than likely would have secured the
position of chairman but he dropped out
when his desire to become a doctor was
reaffirmed to all Lincoln's recovery
however lei aura was now a famous figure
amongst the Association and would remain
heavily involved with their affairs
after being approached by the Zodiac
cheadle to accompany them on an
expedition to the Dark Continent with
the Oreo himself being granted the
zodiac title of boar in the process
which interestingly enough was the same
title that Jing had previously held and
they Oreo accepted this proposition
after being permitted to study medicine
under channel for the duration of the
expedition and so they Oreo currently
resides in a medical facility aboard the
black whale one which is rather
dangerously serving as a stage for the
succession war of the cocoon Empire
small fun facts about the audio the
audio is last name Friday night is a
portmanteau of the English words paladin
and Knight and furthermore this name was
not revealed until much later in the
series during the events of the 13th
hunter chairman election despite being
one of the four main protagonists of a
shounen manga the audio still has yet to
actually engage an opponent in a proper
fight and when I say a proper fight I
don't mean the brief skirmishes it's
like the ones he faced against Hisoka
and Jing I mean an actual shown in
battle on a similar note Lee arias
weapon of choice would appear to be a
classic switchblade although he has
never actually used it against a human
opponent due to the whole not having
been in fight thing whilst the manga and
2011 anime incarnations of Honda hunter
did not reveal the name of lair areas
childhood friend who passed away the
1999 anime version took some liberties
in this regard I was doing him with the
name of Pietro the audios birthday
happens to fall on the Japanese festival
of hina matsuri or Girl's Day which also
happens to be the day that the hunt
under manga began serialization being
March 3rd also worth noting is that Lee
arias birthday just as was gon kill
Walker Deepika and Hisoka
share the same number in regards to both
the day and the month with his being the
third over the third and finally a truly
useless fact in 2013
the winner of Miss Universe Japan
specifically mentioned the audio when
she was asked about what type of man she
likes but that pretty much does it for
the audio if you enjoyed this video and
the content the channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps support this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
ori takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured in
the next Hunter hunter 101
my name is Lee audio and I like to point
I appointed kids I pointed me I point at
you nobody is going to stop me pointing
and that is the point now if you'll
excuse me it's time to read some vintage
pornography